[Music]
hey everybody so as promised this is
gonna be a video explaining what's going
on behind the scenes at DC movies what's
going on with the Justice League shared
universe how all the films going forward
are going to change and how some of the
faces like Ben Affleck's Batman face are
going to change in the next couple of
movies so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be a whole
bunch of comic book stuff dropping
between now star wars in the end of the
year so because it's all still so crazy
I'm still doing that ticket giveaway
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this but starting with the big report
first you may have read that the people
that are responsible for making the DC
movies like Geoff Johns John Burt are
changing their roles just a little bit
so John burg was technically Geoff Johns
boss they've been creative control at DC
movies for about the past two years or
so a couple years ago when they were
still making Batman V Superman and
ramping up for Justice League they sent
John Berg and he was the person who
would sit around on the set of those
movies making sure that everything went
the way that the company wanted it to go
I've already done a couple videos about
Geoff Johns involvement with this
universe so he had Deborah Snyder up at
the top who's president of DC
entertainment and then within that you
have Geoff Johns and John burg that are
sort of helping out with the film's but
they really didn't put those people in
place until they had started to ramp up
for Justice League and because there's
so much money involved in so much
pre-production by the time the Batman V
Superman hit theaters and got this big
critical backlash they had already
started shooting Justice League so they
were way too deep in it to make any kind
of changes or pivot the way they wanted
to so that sort of led to the
circumstances behind the Franken movie
that Justice League turned into so the
same thing that happens every time a big
big movie franchise doesn't make the
money that they wanted to make a bunch
of people either get fired or they get
moved to other departments so what the
reporting is is that John burg is
leaving his post as sort of the de-facto
person in charge of DC movies and he's
going to become a producer with the
people that make the Lego movies and
it's something that he asked to do
earlier this year which gives you an
idea that the people at Warner Brothers
knew what was probably going to happen
with Justice League they probably
that it wouldn't make as much money as
they wanted to so a bunch of these
decisions about people getting shuffled
around in the way they're changing the
way they make the actual movies probably
got made way earlier this year like when
you heard about Joss Whedon coming in to
finish Justice League they actually
asked him to do that way earlier this
year they just didn't announce it till
during the summer till they were already
actually doing it so anytime you hear
about an executive behind the scenes
getting shuffled to another department
like John Burke they probably made that
decision months and months ago so that's
sort of what's going on behind the
camera Geoff Johns is still gonna
continue to advise on the film's they're
still making all of the films that they
said that they were going to make
aquaman still coming out next year
they're still making Wonder Woman -
they're still gonna do the flashpoint
movie Matt Reeves is still gonna do his
Batman movie they have the Shazam movie
that's in development right now none of
that stuff's gonna change the only thing
that's gonna change behind the scenes is
the way they deal with each of those
filmmakers and how much they try to
shoehorn them into the same shared
universe so a little while ago when they
made that announcement Geoff Johns
clarified that all the movies would
still be connected it's just gonna be
more of a Wonder Woman situation where
it's kind of its own thing and you just
have bookends like Wonder Woman's
picture they give it connective tissue
with the other films and the other
characters but for the most part each of
the films won't have plot points
shoehorned in setting up future movies
like they won't have to deal with
setting up another Justice League movie
even though there will be another
Justice League movie eventually but
probably not until we have our new
Batman so the other real big thing that
everybody's talking about right now is
is what's going on with Ben Affleck when
is he going to leave and when are we
gonna see our new Batman what all the
trades have been reporting is is that he
will serve out his contract through the
flashpoint movie they'll change whatever
they want to change with the time line
so that when Barry goes back and allows
his mother to die as he does during
flashpoint we'll get an ending that will
fix the logic of why Batman looks
different the next time we see him
whether or not we actually see him
during the flashpoint movie my early
theory about that is that they would
just do flashpoint with Ben Affleck and
whatever Thomas Wayne Batman they want
to do let him ride off into the sunset
and then when
you get to the Matt Reeves Batman movie
a couple years down the road then you
introduce your new Batman for the first
time so what that means is is because we
probably won't see that Batman movie for
minimum two years maybe three years the
next Justice League movie probably won't
drop for four or five years which I'm
totally fine with if they want to get
everything in order set the characters
up in a way that makes you care about
them before they put them together in a
movie I think it'll be better for
everybody I think the real question is
is how much are they legit going to try
and retcon stuff with the flashpoint
movie or if they'll just let flashpoint
be a self-contained story that's a
little bit smaller and then when you get
to later movies with different actors
and recast roles they don't bother to
explain it they're just like this is
Batman he's always been Batman what are
you talking about Ben Affleck that would
be hilarious the reason why they'll
probably try to make the logic work is
because gal gadot will be Wonder Woman
for a long time she's enormous ly
popular critics love her and her movies
are doing gangbusters and she's still
very young so she could continue to play
the character for the next 10 years if
she wanted to as far as he's led on and
as far as people have talked about Henry
Cavill is still juiced up to play a
comic book II version of Superman but we
don't have a script or a date for the
next Man of Steel movie so it'll
probably be at least three years before
you see the next Man of Steel movie and
I already talked a little bit about Matt
Reeves Batman movie he said that it
would be connected to the DC Universe
for the story itself would be relatively
self-contained and it might be happening
in the past it might be with a younger
version of the Batman so when he casts
his actor whoever that's going to be it
might not wind up being the Batman in
the next Justice League team up they do
but I think that just depends on how
things work out they just want to make a
really awesome movie and then if
everybody really loves the performance
and the actor then they'll try to keep
him around as long as possible but
hopefully that clears up some of the
confusion just people heard that they
were changing things because Justice
League didn't make as much money as they
wanted to but really the only thing
that's changing is a couple executives
behind the scenes just asked to be moved
to different departments and different
roles in Ben Affleck has been talking
about making a graceful exit from the
universe in a timely manner so I think
that flashpoint is just the opportunity
to do that so if you've read that story
or if you've seen the annum
version of the movie the live-action
version with Ezra Miller will be
something that's a little bit different
but he did confirm that they are doing
the Batman part of flashpoint so heavily
implied that we'll get to see a Thomas
Wayne version of Batman however briefly
but if you have any other questions
about what's going on with the DC movies
just leave them in the comments below
I'll be doing videos for Aquaman and all
that stuff when they start dropping
teasers they already dropped the first
picture of him this is him in that
Aquaman movie because the movie isn't
coming out till late next year it might
be a little while before we see some
actual footage but they'll release the
teaser relatively soon there's a bunch
of movies dropping in the spring that
they'll probably try and attach it to
the other big behind-the-scenes comic
book stuff that's going on is all the
Fox Marvel stuff supposedly there at the
fine print stage of the deal just sort
of haggling over what gets to happen
with very specific things what they do
if the government tries to break them up
in an antitrust case but for the most
part people are reporting that it's
almost a done deal but the important
word there is that it's almost a deal so
don't hold your breath until you
actually see somebody hold up a contract
and say everybody signed we now own all
these characters there's a brand new
spider-man trailer that's gonna drop
tomorrow I'll do a video for that
there's also brand new Titans we might
get Donna Troy on that TV show so I'll
be doing a video for that soon too
there's a new round of the IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video congratulations to the winner
from my last DC video whack W please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for a brand
new flash trailer and click here for
brand new Star Wars the last Jedi thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight